Well hello everyone, I'm so excited to be
here.
I'm Jack Mustard, I'm at the Department of
Earth, Environmental and Planetary Sciences
at Brown University, and I'm the co-director of the Earth 4-D Program at CIFAR, and while I live in Rhode Island
I also went to school at UBC, and did a summer mining coal in Hinton, Alberta.
But let's move on to what the program is tonight.
So, to explore is so human.
That's one of the things we do every day,
is we want to know what's around the corner.
And certainly for the first explorers, there
was this drive - this human drive.
That's what Canada's built on - explorers.
The First Nations people who came across the
Poles were explorers.
And then the Europeans looking for that Northwest
Passage.
They were explorers.
So we're all explorers.
But exploration is hard.
It's cold, it's dark....
So the idea here is - one of the things we're
interested in - is there life beyond the Earth?
And so one of the questions we have is, is
there life on Mars?
It's one of the first places we look, David
Bowie - I quoted that for you to get you started
- but we don't know.
We actually don't know how life got started
on this earth.
And so one of the things we're interested
in, I'll answer that question for you in a
moment, is there life on Mars?
If there is life on Mars, but this is the
fictional view of Mark Watney played by our
good friend there, and he's showing there that exploration is difficult.
He's alone, for so long, and exploration is
very alone.
Which gets to our question that we have - are we alone in the universe? That's one of the
questions that drives me, very much.
And where would you go to look for the evidence
of there having been life off this planet?
And it is that - that question actually does
start with the Earth itself.
Because we want to know where we got our origins
here on this planet, and we have to go deep
in time to do that.
So as we explore Mars with spacecraft, and
other things, we've learned that it's a very
Earth-like planet.
It has canyons, it has polar caps it has other things that look very much like we see on Earth.
But it's also very different.
And that's the thing we want to know.
One of the things that happened early on in
our exploration of the Martian system is we
found this rock on Earth which has these forms
on it that looked very much like they were
fossils, on a rock from Mars.
And that got people very excited.
Had we found the life that would be on Mars?
Turns out that all those pieces of evidence
were not pieces of evidence of life on Mars,
they were teasers.
But it led us to say, "How do you go about
looking at a planet that's as big as Mars,
and look for evidence that there may have
been life there or there is life there today."That's
kind of a difficult question.
And we're trying to explore the boundaries
of life to get to that point.
And that starts in some ways, with just defining,
what do you need to live?
So think of this green box as the sweet spot
that all life needs to live.
That life needs to have nutrients, not too
many or you'll be toxic, or not too little
or you'll starve.
You need to have enough energy to make that work, and you need to have enough water.
So those are the boundaries that we're looking for.
And we can look throughout all Earth's habitats
and dark corners to find out where that is.
If we try to find out where Earth began, on
the Earth, we can look at this clock of the
life that we see, and we can look at the clock
of life, and we start with humans, and we
go back in time, and we get to this point
where the planet is only unicellular, and
then we reach this gap, where we do not have
any evidence of what was going on on the surface
of Mars at this time.
Sorry, surface of the Earth at this time,
I'm sorry.
So this is a big problem, if we want to understand
where we came from.
Just like, where did life get started on the
Earth, let alone other planets.
So there's this theory out there of how life
got started.
And Charles Darwin put it nicely, as in the
warm little ponds.
Somehow, it came together, and that's really where we are
in our thinking is, somehow it came together.
and the idea is, that you've got to form cells.
You've got to form some way to encapsulate
life in the form of these particular pieces.
So these are some of the ideas that we all
have, that it could be in hot springs, on
the surface or in the ocean floor, or it could
be in these rehydrating and dehydrating pools,
which I think is probably going to be the
likely place to go.
But we still don't know.
How are we going to find evidence for that,
when it's all gone on the Earth, because of
plate tectonics?
Plate tectonics has completely erased every
piece of evidence from the early part of our
planet's history.
So we have to go elsewhere.
And the nice thing is that on the planet Mars,
50% of the surface comes from the time of
4 billion years or earlier on the planet.
And so the idea is, how are we going to go there to do it,
and so one of the ways to do that is to send spacecraft to the surface.
And it's hard to do that.
So from the orbital perspective, we can't
get it all done, but the one way to do it
is to go put a landrover in a bunch of airbags
and launch that to the surface of the planet,
and we can see that that's a rather rocky
way to land on the surface, but once on the
surface, these spacecraft found immediately,
there were layers of rock, evident for us to see,
and those layers of rock were laid down
by water.
That was one of the ingredients, if you think
about our sweet spot - we need energy, nutrients
and water.
This was a key step forward, and we found
that particular piece of evidence.
And one of the problems with this piece of
evidence was though, it was salty.
Salty and acidic.
And so that was a nice piece of finding, but
it wasn't enough.
We need to find more pieces of evidence that
there was life on this planet.
Exploration is difficult, and it might look
easy to drive across this landscape
but you will get stuck in your wheels up to
your axle, and as you watch this rover try
to get out of its hole, every time you see
this shadow pass across, that's another day.
So that's two weeks of being stuck.
I'm sure you've done that in the mountains,
like your car got stuck in the snow.
Another way we can now go - we need bigger
rovers to do more science.
And in this case we're dropping a rover that's
the size of a Mini Cooper car, we're using
a tether to do this.
And it works.
And we're going to do it again in August.
But that's to get more capable experiments
onto the surface of the planet.
This particular spacecraft has found that
there was a lake that was pretty habitable
in the place they were looking.
Now they're exploring up this enormous mountain
slope to understand more about the planet itself.
And in July of this year, we're going to send
another spacecraft to actually gather samples
to eventually bring back.
Because we realize we can't learn it all just
from the remote observations, we actually
have to go and bring those samples home.
And so they're going to go to this amazing
delta, where the different colours are representing
the rocks we want to bring home, and when we bring those home, you watch out,
we're maybe going to find the answer to that
question.
But before we go, this is going to happen,
possibly, and it may mess up the whole story,
what this is - SpaceX is planning to send
a spaceship in the year 2024, and if they
do that, we hope we get our rocks back before
then because it could change the story.
Thank you very much.